bijoux meubles anciens porcelaine ou
encore armed empire à la foire de chatou
antiquaires et amateurs se côtoient dans
un lieu où le temps semble suspendu
depuis toujours la foire de château est
marquée par la diversité des produits
des oeuvres des pièces présentées mons
l'année comme on faisait deux choses
totalement hétéros qui des deux périodes
totalement différente ça peut aller du
xviiie même dix septième jeu les pièces
du 7e jusqu'au 20e on est venu
aujourd'hui pour pourvoir les différents
exposants et et pouvoir retrouver des
choses d'antan tout à fait pour chiner
un petit peu tout simplement au détour
des allées on échange conseils anecdote
dans une ambiance familiale cette année
l'accent est encore plus porté sur la
qualité des pièces proposées on veille
chaque édition a présenté aux objets de
qualité d'avoir un expert sur place même
deux experts un expert généraliste et
expert en bijoux on veut offrir un
produit top tous nos produits tous nos
meubles sont restaurés sont nettoyés son
propre marche fonctionne ici une vie
normale reprend pour les professionnels
heureux d'oublier un temps la pandémie
qui les a privés d'activités de longs
mois finalement
les gens se sont réappropriés leur
intérieur forcément puisque ils ont
étaient restés bloqués chez eux et du
coup ils en ont profité et en fait
depuis mai l'année dernière on n'a
jamais autant travaillé c'est une
véritable renaissance que d'être
aujourd'hui à chatou la chaleur et la
convivialité
des professionnels restera toujours de
mise et on vous attend tous les jours à
partir de 10 heures que vous soyez à la
recherche de la perle rare ou que vous
souhaitiez simplement être surpris la
foire de chatou vous attend jusqu'au 3
octobre